steely moi je vous avez la chance de
travailler avec vous je sais que laurent
aussi on va vous faire un questionnaire
hanouna ory qui était en galère
d'oseille lequel des deux tu appelles en
premier laurent pourquoi parce que j'ai
déjà demandé j'ai décliné d'ailleurs
mais il m'avait déjà proposé de m'aider
et voilà c'est très loin alors bon mais
je n'ai jamais rien demandé
vous avez bien raison je te dirais
[Rires]
débrouille tout seul alors on est dans
un couloir tous les trois laurent et moi
on repasse devant lequel tu regardes le
plus haut lac estion emballées 2 et de
battre eh bien il va pas taxer tous les
deux les deux lequel des deux pays le
plus et chroniqueur à rien [ __ ]
laurent au n'ont pas dit non à rien
[ __ ] ou plutôt ici parce qu'aux
grosses têtes ça nous oblige à lire la
presse tous les matins comme blanc
fayard de toute la semaine on a très peu
qu'ils font moi j'ai fait un petit peu
quand même donc ça ne voit pas forcément
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand on fait le jeu de sur
l'actualité il ya un vieux ils nous
poussent à une question
laurent sur ce mois ci me pose une
question sur le foot sur le cinéma j'ai
jamais répondre alors bien sûr j'ai
droit la question cinéma à un sport mais
ruiné par coeur s'il veut qu'on échoue
on échouera de travailler comme cyril
moi ça vous fera vous faire un super
point commun ah oui c'est vrai ça c'est
si beau que je gagne je gagne comme ça
on a des points communs laurent et moi à
vous avez tous les deux des qualités
humaines incroyable à ma voix vous êtes
des gens fidèles
certainement oui bah c'est vrai mais non
c'est vrai et c'est vrai chopin elle
fois que vous aussi vous vous allez je
suis rentré chez moi c'est un garçon
très bien qui m'a dit avant de s'effacer
la proposition de revenir ici puisque je
crois qu'il est venu comme invité dans
un premier temps et ensuite vu avait
proposé de revenir il m'a demandé mon
avis et j'ai eu 10 mai coursive asie
c'est forme d'aperçus on voit la c1 avec
mon accord sans problème que c'était sur
ce plateau
alors lequel des deux aiment le mois
catherine barma lors de sa seule en
scène pour dupuis salon je pense que
c'est moi oui c'est je suis en train de
bourgeois mois ne doit pas d'argent
c'est le moment plus de l'argent moi ça
ce serait mal terminée ou données du
site et une qualité et un défaut de
chacun ce serait lequel
tu connais mieux laurent mais bon oui
une qualité laurent y en a tellement
voilà
passage par semaine mais c'est vrai j'ai
la générosité chez laurent a alors ça
c'est sûr que c'est pas moi
un défaut chez cyril alors qu'ils
avaient fait attention à ce que tu dit
voyons un défaut laurent je connais vous
allez les mecs quand vous demandez un
défaut sur un mec qui peut pas donner
des fausses et il est trop perso ça
sèche je cherche un des fours battre yb
l'abri si des fois quand je peux arriver
il dit bonjour à la cantonade moi j'ai
fait un bon temps avec un grand sourire
il dit bonjour à la cantine à des moyens
grands pas mon sourire à la rigueur
c'est tout ce que la ressasser son
principal défaut à ça va un peu cassé
dans 6 6 et devait lui reprocher à
l'autre ils voudraient que je les
embrasse tous les matins mais je
respecte les consignes on se bat pour
tomber dessus laurent est ce qu'il ya
une personne ici qui rêve de faire les
grosses têtes au moins un jour guidon
c'est isabelle moret ben oui c'est vrai
oui oui cm ladi6 alors ya un problème
j'ai fait quoi et pour le lignage ya des
limites d'âge pour
non non c'est de vous donner la règle
c'est quoi c'est que quand je suis
arrivé à airtel pour animer les grosses
têtes et succéder à philippe bouvard
j'ai considéré que je ne prendrais
personne de la station parmi les grosses
stars pour ne pas avoir à ma porte
tous les deux ou trois la raison car de
la station qui viendrait réclamer de
faire partie des grosses têtes c'est
toujours délicat de prendre quelqu'un ou
quelqu'un d'autre
et après vous créez des inimitiés dans
la station pourquoi par exemple vincent
ses rangs très bien vincent perrot alors
qu' il y était à l'époque julien julien
combes et se répandent julien courbet
mais hélas d'autres
tout serait formidable donc je peux pas
prendre non plus isabelle où je pense
qu'on va dire parce que là je ne veux
pas créer de jaloux et de jamais bah oui
laurent ruquier qui sait s'en sortir
avec le sourire